This is the call
that started it all.
SISTER:  Mom fell
and I think she broke her hip.
The ambulance is on the way.
(SIREN WAILS)
STEVE BURROWS: When my mom
went into the hospital
for a routine
partial hip replacement,
we knew something was wrong.
The neurologist told us,
"Your mom is in a coma."
And now it's brutally clear.
I need a lawyer.
MAN: We have not even begun
to recognize
the country's third leading
cause of death,
medical care gone wrong.
The medical profession needs to
be accountable for the errors.
These are our costs.
421,000 dollars.
Meds, health insurance, taxes.
All roads lead
to the insurance company.
Their whole plan is
to drag this out
as long as they can.
WOMAN: (OVER PHONE)
You're a lawyer, am I correct?
No, I'm a comedy director.
This is taking over our lives.
Problems in health care
continue to be endemic.
We're not learning
from our mistakes.
BURROWS: Something has to change
so this doesn't keep
happening to people.